Le reti neurali sono una potente classe di algoritmi di machine learning
e si presentano in molte varianti
non è possibile dedicare la giusta attenzione alle reti neurali
in un video introduttivo
come questo qui identificheremo solo alcuni componenti chiave
di una rete neurale e il flusso di lavoro generale
così possiamo capire come il quantum computing può contribuire
la rete neurale è un grafo connesso di neuroni
un neurone è fondamentalmente solo un elemento che contiene un numero
e quel numero viene spesso chiamato attivazione, quanto
è attivo o inattivo il neurone
i neuroni sono organizzati in livelli
e il primo livello è il livello di input
e l'ultimo è il livello di output
nel mezzo ci sono livelli usati nell'elaborazione chiamati
livelli nascosti l'attivazione del
livello di input viene caricata direttamente dai dati da analizzare
come la sfumatura dei pixel in un'immagine
le attivazioni del livello nascosto successivo sono determinate
dai neuroni nel livello di input
e dai pesi simboleggiati dalle linee che collegano tutti i neuroni
nel livello di input a tutti i neuroni nel
livello successivo in altre parole determiniamo l'attivazione
di un neurone nel livello nascosto
tramite una somma pesata di tutte le
attivazioni di input possiamo
anche applicare un bias, uno scostamento
potremmo voler attivare un neurone
nel livello nascosto non solo se la somma pesata è
positiva ma solo se supera una soglia elevata
poi spesso applichiamo una funzione complessa per ottenere un'attivazione
tra zero e uno come una tangente iperbolica
o a volte in modo diverso una
unità lineare rettificata non devi preoccuparti
troppo di queste cose adesso la cosa
importante da notare qui su queste funzioni
è che sono non lineari
in modo che la rete nel suo insieme contenga sia componenti lineari
che non lineari
la stessa somma pesata delle attivazioni questa volta
partendo dalle attivazioni del
primo livello nascosto con i nuovi pesi
si estende fino al livello nascosto successivo
questo continua fino al livello finale che è l'output
il livello di output ha neuroni corrispondenti alle
categorie e le attivazioni ci dicono
quanto la rete è sicura della classificazione
quindi le categorie di output in un'analisi di immagini potrebbero essere
cane gatto criceto e così via
e un'attivazione di zero virgola novantacinque sul
neurone del cane indicherebbe un alto grado di certezza che
l'immagine raffigura un cane potresti iniziare la tua rete neurale
con un insieme casuale di pesi
e bias o da una configurazione iniziale ragionevolmente nota
ma poi l'idea è di verificare
quanto bene la tua rete neurale classifica le cose
e migliorarla usiamo una funzione di costo per descrivere
come la nostra rete neurale si discosta dalla
classificazione corretta questo implica calcolare la
differenza tra il valore effettivo di un'immagine
ad esempio un valore di uno sul neurone
per cane e zero su tutti gli altri neuroni di output
e i valori previsti
sommiamo su tutte le categorie
così teniamo traccia non solo se la categoria giusta era
la più attivata ma possiamo
anche verificare se le attivazioni errate vengono ridotte
sommando su tutti gli esempi nel nostro set di addestramento
e ottenere un costo poi
variamo i parametri come i pesi in ogni livello
tra tutti i neuroni e i bias su ognuno di essi
vengono usate routine di ottimizzazione classiche
per cercare un minimo locale nella funzione di costo
se non si fa nulla per ridurre la complessità di questo
puoi immaginare che
spazio dei parametri astronomico abbiamo creato qui
considera una rete neurale progettata per analizzare immagini con
solo mille pixel questa rete neurale potrebbe avere mille
neuroni di input un solo livello nascosto
e un output binario come gatto o cane
questo è il caso più semplice in assoluto
e corrisponde comunque a mille per mille
ovvero un milione di pesi tra i livelli di input e nascosto
e altri duemila tra il
livello nascosto e quello di output
possibilmente anche mille o
più bias quindi questa semplice rete neurale corrisponderebbe
a ben oltre un milione di parametri anche se ad essere onesti
gli algoritmi moderni in genere fanno delle semplificazioni
nelle reti neurali classiche
e ci sono interi campi dedicati a rendere questa minimizzazione
possibile e persino efficiente
ma resta il fatto che questo è un problema
ad altissima dimensionalità
e addestrare una rete neurale
può richiedere molto tempo
e può essere costoso una quantum neural network o qnn
funziona prima caricando i dati di input
e poi applicando quantum circuit
corrispondenti ai pesi tra i livelli
e infine un livello di misurazione
alcuni punti chiave su questo i dati
di caricamento e i pesi sono operazioni lineari
ma le misurazioni sono non lineari
quindi come nelle reti neurali classiche abbiamo
sia componenti lineari che non lineari
inoltre i circuit di peso
hanno ancora parametri variazionali
quindi c'è ancora una minimizzazione classica da eseguire
naturalmente questo ha solo scalfito la superficie delle quantum neural
network ma speriamo che tu continui ad apprendere le applicazioni
delle quantum neural network
e altre applicazioni di quantum machine learning
con IBM Quantum